fifty-nine percent of 18 year olds who
voted in the 2012 election voted for
Mitt Romney we're seeing a radical shift
among the younger generation that there
a freedom generation hi I'm Nick Leslie
with reason TV we are at the reboot 2014
conference and we're talking with Evan
Feinberg he's the president of
generation opportunity Evan thanks for
talking to us it's good to ethnic
generation opportunities mission lay it
on us what were you that it gets the
organization we focus on empowering
Millennials sort of the 18 through 34
year old demographic to get engaged in
the political process in a way that
makes a difference to create more
economic opportunity and we certainly
the point of view we think that happens
through more freedom and less government
so what are your key issues so we work
on sort of broad economic issues like
government spending and taxes and
regulation things that are preventing
the next generation from really getting
ahead but we also really are focused on
the issues that are most important to
Millennials so that really creates an
opportunity to branch out and issues
like privacy and and other issues that
young Americans are so you talk about to
talk about privacy like what you know
what what does generation opportunity
think should be done about kind of
federal incursions on privacy well sort
of the the big the big ticket items are
sort of like NSA surveillance issues
we're sort of a bulk collection of our
data something that we're really really
concerned about we're concerned about
putting the hands that information in
the hands of people that really don't
have our best interests at heart we're
also concerned about sort of more more
niche issues like email privacy I think
a lot of young people when they find out
that our emails aren't protected in the
same way that our snail mail is and they
get really really concerned so what is
that it's like after a certain amount of
time basically the government can go
through your email without the type of
warrant they would need to search your
actual physical map yeah most young
people would be surprised to learn that
over 180 days old emails are really open
to any government agency that wants to
use them in whatever way they think
necessary what about economic issues
what are the big economic issues you
guys deal a lot with entitlement
spending old age and tunnel man spending
or you know regulation what are what are
the key drivers there in a lot of young
Americans are really really concerned
about debt and deficits and I think the
recent recent poll was a really good
example of just how cancer
earned young Americans are with all the
money we're spending that's being
charged to the next generation we call
it a war on youth and young people are
there support immediate and title
entitlement reform they don't think it's
a fair just way to run an economy and
they understand those programs were
created in an era where people at the
age of 65 we're either dying or poor and
that's no longer the case and so young
Americans really pushing back against
lobby so I mean are there specific
things you say we should get rid of
Social Security or Medicare should be
means-tested or like how do you how do
you go about you raise awareness of the
issue but then you also have preferred
solutions yeah so I think a big part of
the battle right now is raising
awareness the issue because politicians
in Washington DC just seem so unwilling
to recognize the problem and work
proactively to solve it if they realize
there's a whole constituency of young
Americans that want to see those
problems solved I think that's going to
really compel them to act as far as
specific solutions there's a lot of them
everything from letting young people opt
out of some of those programs to
tweaking around the edges to some
significant overhauls those are things
that young Americans are all interested
in talking about you guys are the people
behind the creepy Uncle Sam ads that
have become kind of viral hits what's
your beef with Obamacare and you know
what do you what do you do now that it's
up and running you know it might be
limping but it's up there yeah the whole
premise of Obamacare is to get a younger
poor generation to pay for an older
wealthier and sicker populations health
care services that's why they've got to
spend so many of their resources selling
young people on this bad deal it's
because our premiums are going to go up
by nearly three times to pay for this
whole scheme it's it's really an unfair
unjust and unsustainable way to run a
health care system it's what happens
when you put politicians and bureaucrats
in charge and so they've got to get Zach
Galifianakis and other celebrities to
try to sell us on this awful so what's
the alternative because the status quo
is not good either right so so what what
what would generation opportunity like
to see happen in health care I think we
need some pretty significant reform that
means taking a look at the tax code that
really benefits an industrial era
employment system where you used to be
you got a job and you stayed in that job
for 20 30 40 50 years now we don't do
that anymore so we're jumping jumping
ship on our jobs at every couple of
years or less so I think we need to
change the tax code to stop biasing
employer-based health care and take a
look at some other
other policies that really start to
empower the consumer to be in charge of
their health care young people really
appreciate in value those solutions can
the GOP move forward with Millennials if
it remains the party of social
conservative so to give some hope to
Republicans among Millennials if you
take a look at 2012 where everyone
talked about how obama won the youth
vote overwhelmingly and he did was sixty
percent of the vote but 18 19 and 20
year olds each voted for Mitt Romney
fifty-nine percent of 18 year olds who
voted in the 2012 election voted for
Mitt Romney we're seeing a radical shift
among the younger generation that there
a freedom generation they're looking for
solutions to the big problem space in
our country and they're looking for
those solutions outside of government so
I think that's the real opportunity for
Republicans but if they're talking about
divisive issues the ones that divide us
rather than unite us they're not going
to win over the next generation so then
you'd have a forward-thinking solution
based entrepreneurial vision for the
future of our country which means
allowing innovative companies like the
uber and lyft of the world and and
allowing those ideas to flourish rather
than talking about the issues that
really divide and prevent our generation
from really uniting behind their
principles in their policy Thank You
Evan for talking to us we've been
talking with Evan Feinberg he's the
president of generation opportunity it's
a millennial outreach group for reason
TV I'm Nicholas
you